で もう一度説明初めからします
別な次元で で このこの同じ偈でも
この解釈っていうのは一つで終わらないんです
かなりのことをお釈迦様おっしゃっています
それは相手の理解能力に合わせて言うんです
だから それ以上言ったって意味がないんですが
わけがわからなくなっちゃいますからね
だからこの必ずもう失尊するなりに自分の知識を出すなりにしない限りは仏教はわからないんです
だからこのしょうがないんですけど
で ドゥーランガマンっていうのは距離がないということで
遠くへ行くという意味で
例えば心を調教したならば
心は簡単に行かせることができます
我々はこちらにいて 大阪のことを思い出すと
本当に今現在にある大阪を思い出しているわけじゃないんです
大阪に行った時 過去の大阪を頭で思い出しているんです
そうしちゃうと心が遠く行ったわけないでしょうに
ただ 時間は瞬時に走っただけのことなんです
過去に  5年間も大阪に行ったことがない
5年前には行きましたと言ったっても
瞬時に思い出せる ということは瞬時に５年遡ったっていうことでしょ
で  60歳の人に母の小学生の時
お母さんのことを思い出してくだちゃちゃうと瞬時に思い出しちゃうでしょうに
ということは 54年瞬時に遡ったということなんです
それは心の速さなんです
しかし この何といいますか
その時 その瞬間のものは思い出したことではないんです
距離は飛んでないんです
仏教では距離は飛べるとは言っているんです
では 大阪のことを思い出しますよと言ったら
もう過去の大阪を思い出す
みんな 私たちには本当はその能力ないんです
お釈迦様は堂々とおっしゃっているのに
遠く走りますよと だから前のたとえ一応言いましたけど
大阪のことを思い出すでしょうし
だから体で行くならば 2時間半もかかるのに
1秒もかからないですぐ思い出しちゃったんだから
やっぱり距離はなく 遠く飛べるんだと言ったんですが
実際は飛んでないんです
ただ時間を遡ったんです
だから我々には時間的に過去に飛ぶということは不確定なんですけど
たまたまできる それも確定して一定したものじゃないんです
思い出せたり 出せなかったりする
思い勝って思い出せたのに
今思い出せない場合もあるし
方程式がないんです 何か何て言いますかね
これは このアットランダムで思い出すだけ
だから思い出すっていうことは
心はもう時間を飛んで過去に行くということなんですけど
それがあまり確定してある調教していないんだから役に立たない
アットランダムなんか似てる日本語の単語ないんですかね
気まま  ん？ 気ままではないですね
なんかそんな似てる感じでね
無作為って言ったら無作為っていう
無作為でいいんですよ
それは無作為な 無作為？ 無作為
作為がないっていう  無作為ですね
だから何か思い出すんですけど
もうそれで終わっちゃうんですね
じゃあではこれを思い出してくださいったら
それがもう無理なんですね
しかし もう作為的に狙ったものを思い出すということは大したもんですよ
頭がいい人っていうのは
いくらかその訓練がある人なんです
いろんなことを勉強して
それはもう作為的に思い出せる
それで我々すごい頭がいいと言うんです
だから無作為的にいろんなことをもうポツンポツンと思い出したっても
なんか役にも立ちません
そういうことで 一般人には心は距離を飛ばせる能力はないんです
だから今現在今の一秒の大阪は思い出せないんです
しかし 心に距離がないんだから思い出せるはずなんです
今の時間の大阪を 今の時間のなんかを
今実際するものであったら思い出せるはずなんです
心ならいけるはずなんです
だからそれはやっぱり心を調教した人にしかできないんですよ
だから心育てた人がもういとも簡単に知って
まあ心には別に距離がないんだよと
例えば心を育てた人だったら
じゃあニューヨーク 今の三十四十年でしたっけ？二分ですからね
今ニューヨークではね
あちらこういうことありますよと
こちらこういうことを受けてますよと
何のことなく言えます
その場合はテレビよりも衛星の放送よりも早いんです
それは物質通してくるんだから時間かかるんです
だから宇宙のことで距離がないんだから
宇宙のことであろうと
今はこういうことが起きてますよと
と経験することできます
だから この仏教でなんか神通とか
こんなのは嘘とか何とか言うんだけど
嘘やという人の自分が私はもうとてつもない救い難い無知な人だと言ってるだけの話で
自分の頭悪いんだからって他人のせいにするなんて意味がないでしょうに
仏教から見れば そんなのはごく常識的な
普通は当たり前の心の能力なんです
無作為的に過去を思い出せることは
作為的に思い出せるようにすれば
それでいくらでも時間飛べるでしょうに
そこをもうちょっと踏ん張れば
もう距離的にも飛ばせることはできます
そうすると 今の瞬間でニューヨークを見ようと思っちゃ見られるし
今の瞬間でパリはどうなっているのかとしようと思えば知るでしょうし
それはこの天眼という仏教でいうと神通なんです
先生 あの 歯が浮いたわけじゃないんですけど
あの心ってのは体を通して何か見てるんじゃないかっていうやつなんですけど
そういうことは関係なく
その場その場でその瞬間でなんか体を使うんですか
うん だから体通してる間はもう体は乗り越えられないんですよ
感覚器官も何もないんですか？ だからそれ違うんです
だから体に依存している場合は
体通して場合は空間を飛べないんです
それ言ってるんで だから今なんでお釈迦は見えないのかというと
体を通して見ようとしてるんだからなんです
はいはい  私の財布の中に今いくら入ってるかわかる？ うんうん
財布の中身を 財布の中身を知ることができ
彼の財布の中身がいくら
わかる人はわかるでしょう
そんなのわかります 札束だけ
札束  私は知りません 知りません
知りたくもないし はい
思い出すことができるっていうお話だったんですけど
それ思い出すということは
ある経験があってっていうことですけど
今のお話をこう聞いていきますと
経験がないところでも
今この瞬間にちょっとここのとこのところになりたいっていう風に心が思ったとしたら
ば 瞬時にそこを出そうと
その瞬間には経験することが
できます うん 今の現在知る場合は経験はないんですからね
思い出す場合は過去の経験でしょうしね
そもそもその指の先すらも見てないんじゃないですか
その時 結局ここからここまで光が飛んでくる間は時間が遅れてるわけですから
結局自分が今見てるっていうもの自体も今見てるものじゃないわけで
ほとんどのものは だから本当にこう
体のちょっとも出ることがなくて
もう完全になんか見ることだって目のこの 1点だけでしか
そこにしかいないじゃないんでしょうか
それはその通りです 時間はそれてます
知る時はもう終わってるんです
どこでも行ける状態っていうのは
そういう壁はもう完全に破れてるっていうわけですよね
物質の壁破れるんです
光にも当たりがあったり
ないんですよ  夜は光の
うん  本当に時間の差ってのは瞬時
で あの だから時間の関係なく知ることはできますけど
心にも心の法則があります
だから心は時間取っちゃうんです
だからもう何でも知ろうと思っても
例えばどんな距離でも飛べる
例えば今の瞬間でパリを見るっていうことをする
で そのパリを見るために心がある一定の時間取っちゃうんですね
だからじゃあパリを見て
じゃあ 2秒後と言ったっても
また別な時間になっちゃうんですね
だから心は直接データを取って
それを処理するための時間
心には必要なんです だからそういうこともあります
だから財布の中身を知ってる
見えてるんでしょうかっていうような質問の場合は
はい そうですよと言っちゃうと
もう何でもかんでも見ているんだと
これは成り立たないんです
そんなことは心にできないんです
常に何でも今の瞬間のこともう知ってることはできるではなくて
心はあるポイントを目指さないと
目指したらそちらに瞬時に行く
行ったら別なところは今行ってないんです
だから別なところに行きたければ
その別なポイントを目指して飛ばさなくちゃいけない
だからそういうことで時間かかります
だからそういう風に心飛ばせる人
能力あっても 決して人の財布の中身は言わないし
知らないし 知ろうともしない
財布の中身を 別に財布の中身って何？ いいや
それ私も例えで言うんですからね
例えばこういうことでお釈迦様がこの羅城城寿泉にいて
別なところに行きたくて
行ったことがないところに
ただ単に行けばいいんですけど
どうですか 道はとかね
そこら辺の人を聞くんです
聞かなくてもいいんだけど
そういう余計なことをする必要はないんです
どうしても大変な問題が起きて
どうしてもこれは知っておかなくちゃ
もう大変やというとこだけ心を飛ばすんであって
でなきゃ別に 普通にいる
それはこの真相があるとも知らない人にとっては
なんでそれ？ってもったいないではないかと思うかもしれませんだけど
法則を知っている人にとっては別にもう考え方まだ違うんですよ
こういうことを考えてください
今も心がごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃいろんな過去のことを思い浮かんでは悩む
思い浮かんでは悩む それで日常の仕事もできなくなっている
仕事にものすごい立ち触っている
触りがある もう時間がない
かなり苦しんでいる だから
情報を知ること自体は
心にとってはすごい苦しみなんですよ
今の体で情報知ってることも
それも知っていて 体に依存しない状況を作った人は
もっとより大きいスケールを理解して情報を知るということはありえない話なんですよ
例えば 手に手の上に何か燃えているんだと
手の上で燃えているものはすごく熱くて
火傷してもう危険でしょうね
それが分かった人が山火事のど真ん中に飛びそうっていうことはありえないんですよ
だから言う 手の上で何か燃えているんだから
あなたには落ち着きがない
あなたに本読む暇がない
テレビ見る暇もない だから早く手の上にある火を消しなさいと
言ったと それは当たり前の理屈でしょうね
それで人間が頭の中で体のことばっかし
あらゆる無作為的に過去のことばっかし考えて
必死で苦しんでるんです
体のせいで で 体を認識するんだから苦しいんであって
体を認識しなきゃ苦しくないんです
だから認識すること自体が苦しみそのものなんです
過去 過去であろうか 人のことだろうが関係ないんです
今現在 この環境を認識することも苦しみなんです
見ると苦しい 聞くと苦しい
味わうと苦しい 嗅ぐと苦しい
それなのに心は体だけに依存している
もっと力があるんです
それを証明しようと体の次元を破った人がありったけのことを知るということはありえないんです
では 知って あれも知ってやるぞ
これも知ってやるぞと
なんかバカバカらしいんです
分かればありがたいんですけど
あの なんでより大きく苦しむなくちゃいけないんですかね
ちょっとイメージしてみてください
ある人がこちらに座っていて
今現在 宇宙にいろんな場所にピンポイントして
あちらはこうなっている
こちらはこうなっている
こちらはこうなっていると見ていると
すると これって楽ですかね
苦しくて大変でしょう
今 目に見えるものにしたっても
苦しくて大変なのに 時々見ないことにするんだから
カーテン閉めちゃうんだから
見えないようにと そういうことなのに
もう知る能力 見る能力を広げたんだからといって
もう で 私は知らない世界から例え出しますけど
あの望遠鏡という機械があるんです
あるみたいんです それで望遠鏡というのはおもちゃ売り場でも売ってますが
それでは木の葉っぱもろくには見えないんです
あの おもちゃ売り場で売ってる望遠鏡で見るよりは
普通の目で見た方がよく見えます
でもあれもおもちゃといったっても
それなりに結構レンズがついていて
まあせいぜい 8千円とか 1万ぐらい値段つきますからね
でも 8千円の 1万円の望遠鏡と違う望遠鏡もあります
億単位でお金かかって作っているものも
それでこの巨大望遠鏡ではどんな距離でも見られるでしょうに
高らでて望遠鏡を当てたところですべて見てるんですかね
見てないんですよ それはものすごい専門家でないと使えないんです
専門家が何で必要かというと
この見たいところだけにピンポイントするためなんです
それで どうしても見ておかないといけないところにだけピンポイントして
それだけ見るんですよ
だからデータをたくさん取るんじゃなくて
遮断シャットアウトするんです
この望遠鏡っていうのはそんなもんなんです
素人から見ればいっぱい情報を取る機械だぞと
違うんです かなり遠くも 1光年前の星でも見ているかもしれませんだけど
すごいデータ取ってるんだと
逆法則なんです 遮断する
物質の世界でも心を探るときも同じことなんです
だから瞑想して心のレベルを向上するということは
もう遮断することで成り立つんであって
開放することで成り立つんじゃないんです
そんなことを言ってもね
わからへんでしょう  望遠鏡でもいじったことあるんだったら
いくらかわかると思いますけどね
目で金星見えるのに まあちょっとまあ
3万  4万ぐらいの望遠鏡買ってきて
では金星を見てください
見えるかと 見えないんですよ
使い方わからないんだから
混乱するだけだったら目で見た方がいいんです
あれは金星やと 土星の輪っかなんかは普通の望遠鏡で見えるみたいんです
だったら見てください
結構大変ですよ その土星だけに合わせるっていうことは
しかし 望遠鏡っていうのはこの距離をカットしています
距離を伸ばしてるんです
目だったら見えないのに
目のレンズの力はどれぐらいかとハッキリしているんだから
この小さなレンズしかついてないし
それにはまあこれぐらいしか見えないということで
それで目の裏のあれ 膜も適当に伸ばしたり縮めたりすることもできんでしょうね
だから目の能力はもう決まってる
その代わりに それより目よりは伸ばしたり縮めたりことをすることできる望遠鏡を使う
その時点で我々は遠く距離を見られる能力は手に取ってますが
見えないんです それでどうしても見たい場合は
それなりの知識を使って
テクニックを使って 土星だけにきちんと合わせなくちゃいけない
土星だけに合わせてどんどん近寄る
近寄って見ると なんとなく輪っかが見えてくる
そんなところがもう月のクレーターというものを見ようかなと
この小学生なんかに頼んでみてください
どれほど苦労するかというと
目で見える月に調整できないんです
望遠鏡 だから距離を飛ばすということは
それで大変なことなんです
だから あれも知ってる
これも知ってるというふうな気持ちの人にとってはできないんです
何も知りたくない人にだけできる能力なんです
元々知りたくないんだから
あの村にどう行けばいいかと
堂々と人に聞くんです
お釈迦様も だって人に聞けばわかることになんですっごい難しい能力を使うんですかね
だからそういう能力は一般人に言ってはならないんだと
大変なことになるんです
今いい例えですよ 出されたのはね
私の財布の中身知ってますかと
それはすごくいいんです
そんなこと言ったら大体そういう質問するんですよ
超越した能力があるっていうことになっちゃうと
そういう質問する 質問で言ったら別に間違ってるわけじゃないんです
それで中身言ったらもう確かめられるし
あ なるほどと 知ってるんだということは推測できる
でも財布の中言うためにすごく厳しい調整しなくちゃいけないんですよ
心の 望遠鏡を合わせるような感じで
だったら財布を開けて見れば
あの いい あの これはもうからかって
そういう質問なんかはね
あのからかってるエピソードがあるんです
この前もこの同じアビダンマ北教の勉強会で言ったエピソードなんですけど
で お釈迦様はどこか出かけようと比丘たちと一緒に出かけたところで
あの川があって 川を渡らなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様は川のところで待っているんです
で あの渡り船というか
その渡る 何？何人という
その船の人とお釈迦様は結構知り合いみたい
そっちを行ったり来たりするんだから
その人は向こうに行ってるんだから
お釈迦様は向こう側からこっち来るまで待っている
比丘たちと そこで そこら辺の山の中から森からある行者が下りてきて
その行者がそのまま歩いて川の上を歩いて向こうに行ってしまったんです
それをみんな見ているんですね
お坊さんたちもみんな
でももうインドの川だから
もうちょっと幅もありますし
それでお釈迦様はじっと待って
その間に比丘たちはいろいろいろいろコソコソコソコソと喋っているんです
お釈迦様は聞いてない
何も 何はぶしゃべってるかと
そこでこの船の船が来たんです
ほら お釈迦様と比丘たちはどうせタダで渡してあげるんですよ
お金取らない でお釈迦様はあの船の人にね
君 もし君がね お金取るならば
お釈迦様お金持ってないしね
お金取るならば 私とこの比丘たちをみんな
渡す場合はね まあもしかすると一回
二回で渡せると思いますけどね
お金どれぐらい取るんでしょうかって
うん そうですね それぐらいにするだったらまあ五千ですね
あの五千というのは五千円じゃなくて
あの 一の百分 五千 五千
五千ですと うん あ そう
いきなりお釈迦様が比丘たちの方を見て 「
比丘たちよ あの行者の修行の価値は五千です」と言われたんです
だから五千でできることなのに
これ二十年修行するとすると
ちょっと割合に合わないということなんです
だからお釈迦様にもその能力は当たり前あったんですよね
でも俗世間ではいかなる場合でも使ってはいけないということで
お釈迦様は天国からね
天国に説法しに行って
降りたところを堂々と今もあるでしょうに
こちらから降りたんだと
天国から 天国に上がったところはもうルートに簡単に入りますけど
天国に上がって降りたところはちょっと離れたところなんですけど
そういうのはごく普通にあるんで
そういうのは特定の出来事で
その時はそうするしかないという時以外は使わないんですね
でないとやる気にもならないんです
お釈迦様はなんで天に説法しに行ったんですか
うーん 聞きたがったんだからでしょうね
なんで私はあんた方に説法してるんですか
あんた方聞いたんだからでしょ
迷惑なところですけど
来なかったら それはもうただ聞きたがっているんだからやったことでね
まあ天にしたっても 自分の母親に特に説法したかったんです
で これはもう母親に権利があるんだからね
ブッダを産んでもう七日目で亡くなってね
自分だけには説法を聞けないというとね
これはとんでもない ね
悪いしね だからあえて母親のところに行って
真理はこういうものであると教えて
で 暗号はそちらに住んでいて降りてきたんです
そこで仏教はお釈迦様は天国会に三ヶ月間いたんですけど
ご飯は人間のご飯を食べていたんです
向こうでそれ何もできませんよ
だからもうサーリプッタ尊者かナーガサーリプッタ尊者か
その弟子 大弟子二人がサーリプッタ尊者ですね
で ちゃんと托鉢をして
で 待ってるんです サーリプッタ尊者と会って
サーリプッタ尊者のご飯をいただいて
食べて召し上がって また天国に戻るんです
ほんのちょっとの時間で誰も見たことはない
それは 忙しいんだから
だから天国で喋った説法はほとんどサーリプッタ尊者は知ってるんです
それで暗号終わったんだから
まあ堂々と なんで隠れるんでしょうかということで
このサンキッサというところで降りたんです
まあだからこれはもう
あれは特別な出来事で
それ以外はもう どうしてもやらんですよ